[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire football ce
dimanche 26 mai trappe s'est imposé 4 1
sur son terrain contre les mureaux
victoire qui permet au club de monter en
r2 et de prendre la première place à la
c1 boulogne billancourt
les détails dans ce magazine foot us
samedi 25 mai les templiers d'elancourt
en caler en play-off de 2e division qui
ont été abattus par les gladiateurs de
la queue en brie en demi-finale
conséquence les élans courtois ne
monteront pas la saison prochaine en
première division le résumé du match
gymnastique les championnats de france
par équipes étaient organisées pendant
trois jours au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
parmi les mille cinq cents gymnastes
présent des sportifs de la gemme et
encore parcouru en division nationale
une
le résumé de leur compétition
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on prend tout de suite la direction de
trappes l'étoile sportive a terminé de
la plus belle des manières sa saison en
assurant à la fois la montée en
régionale 2 et le titre de champion de
régionale 3 lors de cette dernière
journée
récit d'un après-midi de rêve pour les
trappistes des images de nicolas landry
un montage de pierre guillon
la musique de la ligue des champions
pour débuter ce match capital trappe
recevait les mureaux lors de l'ultime
journée de r3 en cas de victoire
associée à une défaite de boulogne
billancourt les trappistes pouvait être
champion
une source de motivation pour les
joueurs qui mène à rapidement un puis
deux puis 3 0 après une première période
spectaculaire
c'est une très bonne chose
facilité non plus commence à déjouer
certes rien à jouer mais je vous jure ça
permet de garder sa vocation est de leur
dire que au delà du fait de terminer
meilleure défense aussi de chercher
cette première place et qui se passe
vraiment vraiment est amplement méritée
et tout le mérite leur en revient
de retour sur le terrain trappe se fait
surprendre sur corner par les mureaux
l'équipe de hicham mardi souffre mais
arrivent à faire la différence en contre
les trappistes inscriront le dernier but
de leur saison en fin de match score
final 4-1 de son côté boulogne
billancourt s'inclinent 4 à 2 sur le
terrain tony trappe terminent premiers
du championnat
[Applaudissements]
on récupère cette première place qu'on a
occupé les trois quarts de l'année ça
fait vraiment plaisir tout le mérite en
revient aux joueurs au staff au sikkim
en un qui m'accompagne à la direction
qui m'a fait confiance cette année est
vraiment fier aussi déterminé meilleure
défense de la ligue de paris sur la
saison n'a encaissé 12 buts cc c'est
énorme c'est énorme c'est vraiment peu
et c'est une grosse saison 0 5 buts par
match c'est ce qui a fait notre force
cette saison très fier de temps tant
d'années qu'on cherchait sa le club
il est beaucoup d'investissement de
joueurs d'efforts de sueur de rigueur et
away très fier de faire pour vraiment
monter ce club moi l'équipe la régionale
2 un niveau attendu par les trappistes
depuis 35 ans pour réussir sa saison
prochaine le staff veut conserver son
groupe en y ajoutant de l'expérience
avec un objectif en tête le 28 on
continue par du football et le
championnat de nationale 3 très belle
fin de saison pour versailles les hommes
de la cité royale se sont imposés 4 à 2
sur le teint de créteil lusitanos cette
ultime victoire permet au versailles de
prendre la deuxième place du championnat
à quatre petits points du premier les
gobelins cette magnifique saison ne
permet pas malheureusement au club de
monter car seul le champion peut aller
en nationale 2 dans le championnat de d1
de district ont joué la dernière journée
maurepas s'est imposé 4 à 2 face à
guyancourt
le chesnay s'impose 2 1 sur le terrain
de sartrouville où dominent hardricourt
2-1 marly-le-roi et rig argent ville sur
le score de 5-1 enfin l'équipe 3 du fc
mantois et monte son se quittent sur un
match nul 1 partout au classement
marly-le-roi remporte le championnat
était cinq points d'avancé sur où il ya
une dernière information football coup
dur pour le fc mantois 78 le club qui
regroupe les villes de buch les mantes
la jolie et mantes la ville a été
rétrogradé en nationale 3 la semaine
dernière par la direction nationale de
contrôle et gestion des clubs plus connu
sous le nom de dncg le club avait
pourtant sauvé sa tête en nationale 2
mais le déficit du club a obligé
l'instance à réagir le budget
prévisionnel est passée de moins 25000
euros à moins 160 mille euros la dncg a
donné un mois au club pour trouver
l'argent ce qui est possible selon les
dirigeants de la structure
après une large page football nous
allons parler de football
américains les templiers d'elancourt
cale en playoffs de deuxième division
ils ont été battus ce samedi par les
gladiateurs de la queue en brie en
demi-finale conséquence ils ne monteront
pas la saison prochaine en 1re division
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
en montage de exagère les templiers
sortent déjà des playoffs de deuxième
division ce samedi 25 mai les élans
courtois se sont inclinés en demi-finale
de conférence north face aux gladiateurs
de la queue-en-brie à domicile malgré
une légère avance à la pause 7 à 3 et
l'encours favori craque finalement et
perd 15 à 10 donc très très grosse
déception je pense que on passe
complètement à côté du match comme on
l'a dit en fait à la fin au deuil aux
joueurs en fait c'est c'est nous qui
donnons le match on se tire des balles
dans le pied en fait tout simplement on
a un problème d'attitude de deux fautes
répétées qui
qui nous qui nous pourrissent la vie
depuis depuis quelques années il faut
vraiment qu'on règle nos problèmes parce
que parce que c'est c'est trop triste
d'avoir un potentiel comme le nôtre et
de la loire des résultats en fait si
vous aussi mauvais cette défaite
condamne les élans courteau à rester une
année de plus en deuxième division une
quatrième saison consécutive pour se
relever de cette désillusion des
nouveaux axes de travail sont déjà
évoqués on verra ça cet été là je suis
vraiment j'accuse le coup donc on verra
ça pue un peu plus tard je pense d'ici
d'ici quelques semaines en serez union
avec les coaches avec les joueurs voir
qu'on se parle qu'on met les points sur
les i pour pouvoir repartir à d'attac
l'année prochaine les templiers
d'elancourt reprendront le championnat
de deuxième division en janvier prochain
l'objectif devrait être une nouvelle
fois la montée on continue à parler de
sport us en bsb les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux se sont inclinés deux fois
ce week-end contre les templiers de
senard l'un des favoris du championnat
le score est sans appel 7 à 0 dans la
première partie 5 1 dans la seconde
manche au classement montigny le
bretonneux reste deuxième de la poule b
avec un bilan de 11 victoires et 5
défaites depuis le début de la saison on
louvre maintenant une page gymnastique
les championnats de france par équipes
étaient organisées pendant trois jours
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
parmi les mille cinq cents gymnastes
présentes des sportifs de la gemme
elancourt maurepas ont concouru en
division nationale une le résumer leur
compétition des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude des championnats de
france presque à domicile la gemme
elancourt mort pas connu cela pour la
toute première fois de son histoire
ce samedi 25 et dimanche 26 mai les
athlètes du club devaient concourir à
moins de 10 kilomètres de leur lieu
d'entraînement au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines devant
plusieurs milliers de spectateurs
il va faire un peu peur le fait d'avoir
ses amis sa famille soit derrière nous
alors qu'à l'habitude
ils se déplacent pas forcément ça peut
rajouter un stress supplémentaire et une
pression supplémentaire pour les plus
jeunes parfois mais je pense que sur ses
jeunes fils à lc
elles ont assez de mentales et elles
sont assez préparés pour apponter des
professions après une après-midi de
compétitions intenses les gymnastes de
la gemme elancourt maurepas termine 5e
et arrive à se maintenir dans le
championnat de division nationale une
l'objectif du club avant le début de la
compétition on est ravis elles font un
match quasi parfait
il ya une petite petite erreur à la base
et cédric pardon on a peur que ça lâche
un peu le match en fait elle se
ressaisissent très très bien derrière fo
onu poutre parfaite et un seul parfait
il ya trois notes qui rentre à chaque
fois sans chute
on a la chance d'être sur une
compétition équipe donc on sait très
bien que si on fait une petite boulette
ya forcément une reste de l'équipe qui
revendent idem hier et c'est ce qui fait
notre force on a tout su rebondir sur
les erreurs des autres
une première étape pour le club qui
espère désormais pouvoir viser un podium
en division nationale une dans les
prochaines années
on continue à parler de gymnastique et
de la gemme elancourt maurepas le club a
également réalisé une très belle
performance en dn4 avec un podium une
médaille de bronze qui n'était pas
forcément espérer pour en parler nous
recevons sur ce plateau
morgane goalard vice-présidente de la
gemme elancourt maurepas ainsi qu'éric
matra le responsable de la section
sportive et les gymnastes marlène me
julie mouja mathilde de terre anaïs
guillois et angélina fait irish times
bonsoir bonsoir
alors votre action tout simplement suite
à cette victoire
marlène
heureuse pleine were rempli d'émotions
et effectivement surprise du résultat
ce n'était pas forcément attendu loin
c'est ce que je disais précédemment on
pouvait on savait qu'on pouvait
potentiellement faire quelque chose
après je me blesse le jeudi juste avant
la compétition donc les espoirs est un
petit peu partie donc on espérait
toujours au fond de nous mais on savait
que ça allait être beaucoup plus
compliqué et fallait faire un match
quasiment parfait
eric comment vous avez fait pour le
remettre sur pied rapidement gelé par
mis sur pied selo stokes a déchargé un
petit peu on a attrapé et puis elle est
obligée d'adapter les programmes
elle est passée juste aux barres
asymétriques mais elle a fait un
mouvement parfait et puis ben les autres
ont rassuré derrière on a fait le
travail tous ensemble même si elle
aurait aimé passer davantage
voilà le principal c'est qu'elle ait
apporté sa pierre à l'édifice et que les
équipes et la médaille au bout
morgane très belle victoire un très
belle troisième place
très bon moment pour finir ce week-end
c'était la petite cerise sur le gâteau
dernier podium de la journée du week end
et on finit avec une médaille
donc franchement on peut on ne pouvait
pas espérer mieux pour finir ce week end
mais qu'est-ce qui a fait la force
vraiment du club sur cette compétition
la cohésion peut-être l'esprit d'équipé
on avait vraiment une équipe de
bénévoles
hyper soudé vraiment bienveillante
réactive et efficace
on a eu énormément de compliments de la
part de la fédération française de gym
qui nous disait que voilà il était
vraiment ravi d'être ici hyper bien
accueilli voilà tout s'est très bien
passé et c'est vrai que je pense que
tout le monde avait à coeur que cet
événement soit une réussite
donc voilà on a tous à donner notre
personne jusqu'à encore aujourd'hui au
démontage mathilde s'est également voilà
une famille on peut le dire la gmail
encore pas c'est peut-être ce qui a fait
la force du club sur cette compétition
ah oui vraiment on a fait cela vous
paraît sérieuse mais avant l'aube en
début d'émission c'est un peu plus
compliqué horloge
non enfin le club il est vraiment là
pour nous soutenir et entre nous même
entre nous aussi on est vraiment tout
on est toutes amis et même en dehors de
la gêne du coup c'est ça qui nous motive
aussi aller chercher la médaille c'est
ce qu'on a fait et avec c'est ce que
vous recherchez également je sais pas
s'ils ferment c'est ce qu'on recherche
mais on essaie de
d'avoir sa de l'instaurer de l'inculquer
aux plus jeunes maintenant je ne sais
pas si on y arrive il n'y a pas de bons
mauvais on va dire comportement ou voilà
on essaye nous de faire en sorte que les
filles prennent du plaisir en salle en
compétition et soit plus que des copines
d'entraînement voilà il a fallu beaucoup
travailler pour remporter cette médaille
cd de travail mais l'ice et alors c'est
un mot à dire pour elle ça arrive il ya
une fenêtre temporelle de turin
championnat mais il nous faut des années
de travail pour avoir une médaille et
malheureusement des fois un ou deux
passages tout peut s'écrouler
marlène quel a été l'impact du public
sur le club
c'est juste ça peut être à double
tranchant également à plus de pression
voilà exactement ça peut être beaucoup
plus de pression mais ça peut aussi
également beaucoup nous apporter
et là je pense que pour le coup ça nous
a bien porté
on s'est senti bien sur cette
compétition on a senti
enfin chaque passage
on sentait vraiment porté par le public
et ça a été juste du positif pour le
coup pas trop de pression
sata était du mauvais côté du positif
eric oui il est positif je pense que ça
les a transcendés ça aurait pu
totalement désinhibé mais en fait s'en
sont servis et ça les a portés tout au
long de la compétition est chez soi
devant son public c'est une force dont
ils se sont vraiment bien servi et honda
remercie aussi tous publics étaient là
parce que il y avait peut-être je pas
300 400 personnes vraiment qui était
derrière la gêne au moment de leur
passage appel et je pense que nous
l'entendue d'en bas est légitime même si
elles sont dans leurs matches elles ont
dû l'entendre aussi sur l'adn on l'a vu
une cinquième place c'est ce que c'était
une surprise housse ou est-ce que
c'était plus attendus c'était une bonne
surprise je dirais eric empare avec moi
l'objectif c'était de se maintenir dans
cette division nationale une donc de
faire dans les neuf premières
il faut le faire au minimum nous
viennent exactement voilà sur toutes ces
équipes
le niveau est très élevé on a des jeunes
filles des collectifs france qui sont
dans les équipes concurrentes
on a des jeunes filles étrangères qui
sont qui ont un niveau national dans
leur pays donc c'était assez compliqué
mais elles ont fait un très joli match
comme le disait marie il n'y a pas eu
tant d'erreurs que ça il ya eu deux
petites erreurs au bar mais sur le reste
a su se ressaisir et
et terminer la compétition donc on était
vraiment très content de finir cinquième
morgane vous étiez également dans
l'organisation un petit bilan
mille cinq cents gymnastes 1 c'est ça
sur trois jours c'est ça amusant gymnase
qu'ils ont tous été satisfaits et bat
tous je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
depuis ce matin on a reçu énormément de
mails et de message très positif de la
part des équipes que nous avons
accueilli de la part des représentants
de la fédération française de gym de la
part de nos bénévoles de nos élus voilà
donc je dirais que a priori tout le
monde est content nous on est vraiment
très très heureux d'avoir fait cet
événement on a accueilli à peu près
quasiment sept mille personnes sur le
sur les trois jours donc objectif rempli
largement objective largement dépassé
donc on ne pouvait pas être plus heureux
mathilde en tant que qu'athlète comment
vous l'avez ressenti cette compétition
le recentrage ouais c'était vraiment une
excellente expérience c'est je pense une
chose qu'on une chose qu'on va durer
qu'une seule fois dans notre vie à part
c'est prochainement d'un récit mai
vraiment c'est une expérience qui
restera gravée avec la médaille en plus
c'est deux fois plus
enfin ça restera gravé de faciès
justement ça sera ma dernière question
morgan est ce que un jour on pourrait
revoir des championnats de france ici où
le double national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bas on ne va
pas faire de langue de bois mais oui moi
j'aimerais beaucoup
donc oui je pense qu on en reverra alors
préparez prochaine parce qu'on va pas
épuiser nos bénévoles ils viennent juste
de sortir dans le cas d'une semaine très
intense mais mais en tout cas
non le plus important c'est que nos élus
et vu que la salle s'y prêtait qu' on
était capable aussi en tant que club d'
assumer l'organisation d'un tel
événement que la fédération française de
gym a aussi été extrêmement content de
l'organisation et du lieu à parce que ma
minute rossoneri dans cette salle c'est
magique
voilà et je pense que toutes les petites
appréhensions qu'on pouvait avoir qui
sont liées au lieu et au fait que ce
soit un vélodrome la distance par
exemple de la piste avec le public
finalement tout ça ça n'a pas posé de
problème durant le week-end donc oui moi
j'ai à coeur de refaire l'expérience on
a vécu trois jours magiques intense et
voilà et fatigant tous les signaux sont
au vert en tout cas merci à vous d'être
passé sur ce plateau continuons
évidemment vous suivre sur les
prochaines compétitions on espère de
nouveau championnat de france ici oui le
droit national de saint quentin en
yvelines
on prend maintenant la direction de
viroflay un grand gala est organisé dans
la ville ce week end
au total il y a eu 40 ha sau en boxe
française avec notamment quatre sportifs
russes et des boxeurs portugais en
parallèle plus de 60 rend compte de
canne de combat un sport très populaire
au 19ème siècle était organisée avec un
objectif remettre cette discipline au
goût du jour les organisateurs
envisagent de renouveler l'expérience
dans les prochaines années
un mot d'aviron à présent chef de nage
du quatre de couple poids léger thomas à
baruch licencié au cercle nautique de
versailles a déclaré forfait pour les
championnats d'europe qui se disputeront
cette semaine à lucerne en suisse le
médaille olympique et mondial du quatre
sans barreur poids léger blessé au dos
il ne devrait pas pouvoir prendre pas
c'est une compétition importante avant
cet été
on lui souhaite évidemment un prompt
rétablissement on va maintenant à parler
et solidarité ce mardi à 21 mai
une cinquantaine de sportifs de haut
niveau se sont réunis autour d'une
partie de golf pour participer au
tiebreak une compétition amicale qui
fêtait cette année sa 27e édition dans
les yvelines en parallèle des ces
sportifs ont animé des ateliers avec des
jeunes venus de cinq établissements
évinois la celle-saint-cloud elancourt
traque versailles maurepas on écoute la
fondatrice et organisatrice de
l'événement environics chaplin ils ont
fait de la boxe avec trois champions du
monde ils étaient ils ont fait de
l'athlétisme du football avec trois
stars du psg et on tournait sur six
ateliers donc une journée ensoleillée
extraordinaire la soirée s'est terminée
par une vente aux enchères à but
caritatif on pouvait notamment retrouver
la raquette de novak djokovic ou des
maillots signés par les joueurs du paris
saint germain
au total près de 20000 euros ont été
collectés
on passe maintenant notre page agenda on
commença tajan d'apart du football
féminin la coupe du monde féminine
débute dans moins de deux semaines et
l'équipe de france pourrait briller à
domicile pendant la compétition une
sélection nationale que pourrait
intégrer un jour une joueuse de l'étoile
sportive de trappes océane lecerf
footballeuses a été surclassé cette
année en moins de 16 ans à portrait
océane lecerf 13 ans est l'une des
pépites de l'étoile sportive de trappes
sa passion pour le football a commencé à
l'âge de 5 ans je voulais faire un sport
et je trouvais que ce sport me
correspondait bien j'aime bien jouer au
ballon et j'aime bien courir après avoir
foulé la pelouse avec les garçons à ses
débuts la jeune trappistes joue
aujourd'hui avec les filles et a été
surclassé chez les moins de 16 ans ses
entraîneurs l'ont installé au poste
d'attaquante un choix payant marqué
notre championnat comptera plus de dix
minutes
elle est vraiment doué techniquement
doués techniquement et spécialiste des
passements de jambes la jeune trappistes
fans du pg est également assidus aux
entraînements
la sportive joue quatre fois par semaine
et n'a jamais manqué une seule session
depuis sa première inscription
la dernière a été plâtré elle est quand
même mieux aux entraînements elle a
suivi ce tout
toutes les filles au match au sein des
partis n'est voir était avec elle je
vais pas après l'arrêté non parce que ça
sert à rien des qualités qui lui
permettront peut-être d'accomplir ses
rêves et de devenir professionnel comme
ses idoles marie laure délie ou qu'il y
est née mbappé leppé j'imagine que je
raconte j'ai numéro 9 ou un numéro
d'attaqué voilà mais avant de viser plus
haut scène veut avant tout marqué
l'histoire de trappes la ville de son
coeur et de ses débuts un autre rendez
vous qu'il ne faudra pas manquer dans
quelques semaines le 22 juin prochain la
diagonale des mines sont organisées à
travers le département programme un
trail de 90 km un lot de 48 km et un
dernier de 20 km pour nous parler de ce
rendez-vous nous recevons à la un peu
loos le président organisateur ainsi que
nicolas claire qui va participer à ce
trail bonsoir bonsoir
alors pourquoi avez vous voulu créer ce
rendez vous
c'est une première oui c'est une grande
première
en fait on est avec des amis on est des
organisateurs dans l'âme puisqu'on a
depuis une quinzaine d'années on
organise des courses sur les yvelines
aussi bien le traduis josas le trail
dessert les flambeaux qu'est ce qu'ils
sont assez comique et une course
nocturne et puis ça nous tenait à coeur
de faire quelque chose qui traverse le
départ fort parce qu'on aime on aime
département où se trouve sur iliad et
beaucoup à traverser et c'était un beau
challenge je traversais le département
et on est arrivé un petit peu abattu
raté maturité deux organisations pouvoir
mettre ce genre de projet en place vous
y pensez depuis combien de temps on
vient moi ça fait bien trois quatre ans
qu'on est con on y réfléchit après il
fallait que tous les feux se met un
petit peu au vert pour qu'on puisse
passer le cap
ben voilà on pense on pense qu'on est
qu'on est prêt pour le faire il est prêt
à accueillir des coureurs dans les
bonnes conditions
nicolas claire ça manquait un trail
comme celui-là ça manquait oui oui c'est
un manque un petit peu c'est une
nouvelle expérience dans 78 avoir
l'occasion de traverser le département
de rochefort à mantes la jolie s'est pas
donné tous les jours donc à découvrir
découvrir de nouveaux coins il y aura
plusieurs courses c'est ça oui c'est ça
alors il ya la course majeure qu'est le
90 km l'ultra trail
ensuite on en aura pas pour tout le
monde celui-là nom qui sera pas pour
tout le monde c'est vrai que des gens un
petit peu avertis et préparé comme les
nicolas
meyer a aussi un 48 km qui partira de
saint léger en yvelines et en 20 km qui
partira de cette taille on va traverser
la peu près 26 communes
sur l'ensemble de la course c'est vrai
qu'on a eu un très bon accueil au niveau
des villes pour ce genre de projet donc
c'est intéressant donc vous partez de
mantes-la-jolie c'est bien sinon on part
de rochechouart au niveau libations il
dit et on arrive à mantes la jolie
pourquoi on reçoit on n'y va pas parce
qu'on voulait chercher la pointe sud du
département
et puis et puis on a été très bien
accueillie par le maire de rochefort qui
nous met à disposition et qui nous a
accueillis dans les meilleures
conditions et je pense que les coureurs
seront accueillis dans des très très
bonnes conditions et c'est un village
qui gagne à être connu le met des
visages de reformuler alors il y aura de
nombreuses difficultés
j'imagine qu'elle quels sont justement
des difficultés sur ce parcours ce 90 km
notamment les difficultés les
difficultés de ce type de parcours c'est
la longueur c'est 90 km on laborde pas
tous les jours ça n'apporte pas comme un
marathon de 42 bornes c'est il faut
courir cetc roulant comme on dit dans le
milieu c'est il faut courir alors qu'à
la montagne on a droit de marcher donc
les difficultés c'est courir la chaleur
aussi on arrive au mois de juin mais
loin on peut avoir des pics de chaleur
les barbecues au mois de lasser les
barbecues barbecue c'est à dire bye
barbecue les fêtes entre amis donc il
faut continuer à préparer avec les jours
qui viennent s'entraîner c'est bien ça
prépare et voilà à s'entraîner donc ça
reste des difficultés oui donc pas de
barbecue pour vous au mois de juin non
c'est barbecue pour moi au mois de juin
obligatoire ça fait partie de
l'entraînement
le terrain sera également sec le suppose
au mois de juin est ce que c'est une
difficulté
non non non il en soit c'est mieux c'est
mieux au contraire s'est mué en un
terrain sec en ce moment là l'occasion
de courir sur désormais une organisation
fait des courses pardon excusez moi des
courses un peu humide donc c'est un peu
plus compliqué donc là c'est très bien
justement le disais tout peut le faire
ou pas cette course 90 mètres on a
compris qu'il fallait l'entraînement
mais est ce que les autres distances ton
tout novice peut peut s'inscrire
c'est une question de préparation
là c'est une question de préparation
vaut mieux commencer par la petite
distance si on veut finir après augmenté
en termes de kilométrages tout le monde
pourrait faire un 90 mais après c'est
c'est une question de comment lever vie
jusqu'à la fin on peut le finir en
marchant si on veut et mais faut
repartir après le lendemain pour les
travailler qu'il faut regarder le coup
le goût du plaisir
donc oui non la question c'est oui vous
attendez quand même personne sur cet
événement on attendait à peu près 500
personnes 500 personnes sur cet
événement c'est une première
c'est un petit peu dur de lancer là
c'est une épreuve c'est toujours par
expérience c'est toujours très dur pour
faire adhérer
maintenant je pense que sans prétention
on est un petit peu connus que ce soit
philippe feutre ikea l'organisation des
flambeaux et desserts et moi même on est
un petit peu connu dans l'organisation
et je pense que les coureurs savent à
quoi s'attendre
et qu'on va bien les accueillir donc je
pense que ça ça va aussi booster les
inscriptions sachant que à l'arrivée
c'est un peu une tradition il n'y a pas
hélas et bière à l'arrivée pour avec
modération bien sûr avec modération bien
sûr mais ça permet d'avoir un objectif
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
sa place on souhaite bon courage pour
l'organisation de cet événement pour
rappel la diagonale à des yvelines est
programmée le 22 juin prochain
donc vous avez un peu moins d'un mois
pour vous entraîner ont continué cette
page agenda par les rendez-vous du
week-end en handball féminin monti le
bretonneux termine sa saison sur le
terrain de stella sport ce samedi soir à
20h30 au gymnase de la brossolette un
match sans véritable enjeu les îles y
montaient nous devons terminer à la
huitième place du championnat
mais ce sera l'occasion de voir les
futurs jeunes qui intégreront l'équipe
l'année prochaine toujours en balles
mais cette fois ci chez les garçons
plaisir joie son dernier match en
nationale 3 à domicile ce samedi soir à
20h30 au gymnase nicholas leurs
occasions de termine en beauté une
saison morose pour le club qui sera
relégué
l'année prochaine les plaisirs wa
termineront premiers relégables à 10e
place si vous voulez les soutenir
l'entrée est libre 1 et on termine par
du basket ce week-end s'annonce capitale
pour l'entente le chesnay versailles lui
lcv 60 18 jouera sa montée ce samedi
soir à 20 heures contre meudon sur
terrain neutre à palaiseau lors du final
four de prénationale en cas de victoire
les joueurs de la cité royale valideront
obligatoirement la montée en nationale 3
la saison prochaine
avant même la finale si le résultat est
positif ils joueront le lendemain la
grande finale contre paris ou asnières
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]